welches auto fahren sie gar keins fahren
e bike gut dann sind sie ja jetzt schon
disqualifiziert sonntag noch ein vw bus
ein vw-bus sehr gut ein diesel 1 diese
noch besser
dann kriegen sie von uns auch unser
regierungs siegel diese geeignet
herzlichen glückwunsch dankeschön das
finden wir vielen dank sollte ein
autokonzern politischen einfluss haben
also wenn er dafür sorgt das war in
zukunft auch noch auto fahren können
warum nicht entsprechen sie mir einfach
nach einfach drauf legen gerne ja hier
mit schwöre ich jeden schaden vom
vw-konzern fernzuhalten
hiermit schwöre ich jeden schaden vom
vw-konzern fernzuhalten so wahr mir
matthias müller helfe
matthias müller super perfekte würde es
sinn machen wenn vw direkt die regierung
stellt weil die regierungserklärung
schreibt quatsch nein das werden zu vw
hat die regierungserklärung geschrieben
hat wir wissen ist alle wie bei der cdu
ist die großen lassen immer für sich
schreiben
[Applaus]
wenn vw jetzt hier so ein regierungs
roboter hinstellen würde würde man da
überhaupt ein unterschied erkennen zu
hören weil auf jeden fall also ich finde
herr weil das sehr authentisch
ich bin zwar vom paten
maschinenbauingenieur aber herr weil es
authentischer hätten sich aus mit
robotern halt doch wie ich und das ist
doch eine andere sache ja also ich mag
ihn sehr
das heißt sie ja experte sind die
letzten vier jahre war das jetzt her
weil oder war das schon der roboter das
war herr weiterhin gerecht
die leute haben uns gewählt jvb trotz vw
trotz hobby wie hängt das zusammen weil
wir eine gute politik gemacht haben und
stephan weil auch nicht so langweiler
ist wie heute show immer behauptet wird
der war gut
die noch emotionen je würde nach seiner
wahl eines mit einem lachenden und einem
weinenden auge einerseits eu wir haben
gewonnen andererseits niedersachsen
ciao
lust auf mehr
[Applaus]